e alors soyez tous les bienvenus autour
de la planète à phantom canada
l'émission en direct de radio canada
international service français nous
avons des visages qui n'appartiennent
pas à notre secteur mais qui se mêlent
bien à notre francophonie encore je sais
par mon jeu je lis des livres je tire
toute ma source d'inspiration de ça
alors paloma martinez est avec nous un
jour la section destinée aux américaines
bonjour bon retour deuxième semaine
d'affilée deuxième semaine et ça ne
coûte pas un sou de plus dans une
offense et gratuitement c'est que ça
absolument elle vient de l'espace
autochtone de radio-canada donc elle n'a
rien à voir avec notre service
officiellement mais c'est une ancienne
collègue mais oui je suis toujours là
quand même et en une seule à avoir avec
nous d'autant plus qu'on va parler
d'éducation aujourd'hui c'est notre
thème principal l'éducation les hautes
technologies et comment le canada
progresse vers l'avant ou tentent de le
faire et des fois trébuche de côté
maintenant de la technique 35 ce qui
trébuche
il y a voulu commencer par vous jetterez
bouge beaucoup il ne pourra pas parler
aujourd'hui les hô chi minh au j'ai fait
des signes à d'accord mais il a un
problème de chatouillement gorge alors
les soirées bien arrosées voilà c'est
marie-claude et avec mon mari claude
mestre française
alors aujourd'hui on parle de l'école et
je voudrais qu'on partage notre
expérience personnelle je sais que ça
fait des années que nous sommes plus
passé à l'école je parle de la peau du
primaire vous êtes à l'université en ce
moment paloma donc je sais que je
commence la semaine prochaine on parlera
d'université une prochaine fois oui
aujourd'hui on parle de l'expérience du
primaire d'accord et allume ou
élémentaire dit - répondre à cette
question quand vous étiez jeune ça fait
longtemps qu'elles étaient les nouvelles
technologies à l'école d'enseignement à
l'école à moi je peux vous dire pour moi
ouais mais je suis passé de l'encrier
donc avec
le moment comme on appelait ça la pub au
crayon ah oui oui vous écriviez avec un
homme comme j'adorais ça d'ailleurs
ça sentait bon lancre j'adorais ça fait
de détail en suisse mais on avait un
buvard pour éponger les tâches et oui
j'ai encore tout mais qu'elle gisait à
porter avec moi au canada parce que j'ai
fait mais mon école primaire en france
et je suis arrivé au canada au niveau
secondaire et donc c'est ça alors
c'était une grande révolution dans ma
vie stylo à bille
pour anne-marie salomon nouvelles
technologies regardez c'est vrai que des
fois je vous connais pas connu la pub m
j'essaie de réfléchir aux changements
technologiques et je peux prendre mon
temps pour réfléchir les autres ne bat
pas on utilise et les rétroprojecteurs
oui mais vous êtes donc ce biais là même
les copier j'allais pas une école
primaire stéphane qui est une école
qu'on appelait active c'est pas un col
alternatif une école active et puis là
un fait on était très loin de la
technologie qu on veut l'on voulait
vraiment nous amener à réfléchir et à
faire à connaître d'autres technologies
anciennes en fait on avait notre cour
d'imprimantes mais d'imprimerie comme
comme à l'époque de donc ont placé les
petites lettres exactement donc on avait
cet atelier las de loin d'aider la halle
et la technologie actuelle mais
j'adorerais les cours des imprimeries
alors l'école civ maintenant on va
passer les cols intelligente à peu près
enfin après toutes ces années soixante
ans plus tard alors on a les pieds sur
notre bouton là ce que la même un écran
c'était vraiment ce qu'il se passe comme
il vient d'apparaître à manger spéciale
thierry bonjour bonjour alors il s'agit
de thierry karsenti elle sentit karsenti
avez vous une idée de qui il est
villareal ou non je me rappelle plus
alors j'imagine vous travaillez dans le
monde universitaire dallas écoles
primaires continuent et continuent m'a
demandé au milieu de la technologie widi
chaque fois d'accord nous qui êtes-vous
donc qui alors oui on va vous coûter
dans la réponse alors voilà il est
titulaire de la chaire de recherche du
canada sur des technologies de
l'information et de la communication des
fameux tic un ou des parents des tic qui
y en a un que des journalistes très
souvent depuis 3 4 ans et de parler des
tablettes à l'école de l'arrivée des
tablettes à l'école le débat est
toujours là toujours présent et il est
souvent alimentés par thierry karsenti
karsenti parce qu il trouve qu'il ya
beaucoup de travail à faire de ce côté
là notamment au niveau des écoles les
écoles publiques
c'est qu'elle est là le problème nous
aident des écoles publiques qui a passé
tablettes où ils sont pas autorisés quel
est le débat il ya plusieurs via
plusieurs défis que les écoles publiques
en compte n'est ce conte seront voix
particulièrement au québec c'est qu'il
ya un espèce de clivage qui se crée
entre les écoles publiques et les écoles
privées on a les écoles privées elles
sont 105 sur 129 où tous les élèves sont
équipés pour la plupart de tablettes et
dans les écoles publiques c'est vraiment
les exceptions où les élèves arrivent
équipé d'une tablette alors ça va faire
vraiment des jeunes qui vont faire leur
parcours scolaire avec et technologie et
d'autres qui vont le faire et non pas
avec la plume et l'encrier mais avec des
ciseaux appui des crayons
j'avais une question non j'ai pas de
questions j'étais très attentive à ce
que monsieur quelle voix brisée à
l'heure et là je ne vous voit plus ce
qui s'est passé c'est un problème de la
technologie ça nous sommes toujours là
mais on a encore beaucoup vous en faites
pas on est parti dans alors ceux qui
vivent ce problème entre la présence de
cet outil très pratique qui est la
tablette est ce que ça va changer lé là
parce que ça va devenir un problème par
exemple lorsqu on va arriver au niveau
secondaire
c'est un problème qu'on va traîner
toujours ou un moment donné il ya moyen
de rattraper le retard lorsqu'on est un
enfant et qu'on n'a pas pu s'exprimer à
l'école avec ce genre d'outil bon je
crois qu'il ya toujours moyen de
rattraper ce retard mais c'est quand
même triste de voir en 2017
des outils qui vont faire partie du
quotidien des enfants plus tard dans
leur vie puis plus tard
ne serait-ce qu'à l'université au cégep
ou dans leur vie professionnelle
et quand on dit qu'à l'école on veut
former les citoyens pour demain mais
elle a quand même un petit manque elle
et vous savez en 2017 se former à
l'usagé technologique jeu par peur des
jeux des réseaux sociaux mais les usages
et technologies pour apprendre pour
chercher de l'information toutes ces
autres compétences qui sont importantes
et essentielles
ça devient en 2010 est presque aussi
important que l'apprentissage des matis
coups du français
en vérité les technologies deviennent
des vecteurs ou des outils pour mieux
apprendre français mathématiques
sciences histoire etc
paloma qu'elle répondait vous monsieur
karsenti aux parents préoccupés du temps
passé par leurs sans fard devant les
grands à la maison la plupart des
parents ont la difficulté à contrôler
les temps d'écran à la maison donc si en
plus ils vont le faire à l'école que
répondez vous à ça ben moi je vous
dirais il ya deux choses d'abord c'est
normal comme parents d'être inquiet et
il faut être inquiet comme parents se
montrent déjà qu'on se soucie de ses
enfants dont moi je vois ce très
positivement les parent inquiet par
contre leur respect et leur jeu pensé
parce que on voit le temps d'écran de
façon globale comme si c'était la même
chose mais je ne sais pas si vous avez
des enfants mais avoir un enfant qui
joue à des jeux vidéo violents cinq
heures par jour
de son enfant qui travaille sur
l'écriture d'un livre d'un texte d'une
présentation d'une recherche
mais l'usager complètement différent
alors le temps d'écran ip de tous les
sens en moi je suis bon je pense que ton
des crampes ou technologiques pour
apprendre avec les écrans lcd des études
récentes sont sortis qu'ils ont quand
même que le peu d autant d'histoires qui
a pas d'abus versus entre un enfant qui
passe son temps à jouer ou à socialiser
avec les technologies beloeil de poids
ce souci donc il faut garder
il faut trouver un équilibre entre des
moments avec il s'en est extrait de dans
les moments avec écran il faut trouver
des moments où l'enfant passe du temps à
utiliser les technologies à des fins
éducatives et c'est l'oeil je pense ou
des parents n'arrivent pas à faire les
noirs maintenant il faut posterez l'on
paie mon enfant qui fait quoi ses
parents qu'à 11 heures le soir mes
besoins de son ordinateur dans sa
chambre pour faire ses devoirs mais
peut-être qu'on devrait avoir un certain
droit de regard sur ce qu'il fait
anne-marie en fait là j'ai essayé de
comprendre on les tablettes sont rentrés
dans les écoles mais au niveau autant
primaire que secondaire ou privé au prix
payé très peu l'école primaire au québec
dont on n'est plus dans les exceptions
mais quand je parlais des chiffres
valeur environ 105 sur 129 ans par les
écoles secondaires r oui mais vous
comprendre chaque élève a un appareil
électronique quand il commence en
première secondaire est il là jusqu'à la
fin ça on développe des compétences que
ses autres élèves qui n'auront que le
crumble ou le stylo bic
elles n'auront pas eu parce qu'ils
n'auront pas eu la chance d'avoir ça
évidemment c'est pas toujours simple je
dis ça mais c'est pas toujours rose
l'a13 entre une tablette on n'est pas
envie d'aller chercher des informations
intelligent sur wikipédia on a envie de
jouer aller sur les réseaux sociaux dont
au début on apprend à se gérer avec les
technologies on apprend à faire des
recherches de qu'on apprend une foule de
compétences dont celle de s'autogérer
ceux qui auront jamais eu cette tablette
à l'école cet ordinateur et l'école ne
vont pas décrété dans le propre et ans
comme c'est moi qui dois avoir un
certain handicap quand ils vont arriver
au cégep à l'université ou encore son
marché du travail
oui mais en même temps il y a
prennent quand même il ya des cours
d'informatique même dans les écoles
publiques actuellement aux niveaux
primaire et secondaire
ben j'sais pas caricaturer mais vous
savez c'est toute une différence c'est
comme si on vous donnait votre crayon
une heure par semaine dans le cours de
crayon et la voir en tout temps pour
apprendre les autres matières les
technologies on peut en faire une
discipline où ces corps est mais on peut
s'en servir comme outil pour apprendre
toutes les autres matières et c'est là
toute la richesse du potentiel des
technologies pour l'apprentissage tout
ce qu'il est possible de faire de
l'écriture collaborative quand on nous
tue on peut lire un roman de mettre des
commentaires et voilées qu'on va revoir
les commentaires de ses amis dans la
castille nice de même roman en même
temps stimule la lecture mais tellement
de choses notre possible de faire avec
les technologies on ne peut pas faire
sans mais je dis pas de faire que des
technologies non plus pas en train de
dire sol je pense que même dans ces
écoles où est-ce qu'on allait tablette
ou ordinateur
hong un équilibre aussi à trouver mais
mon souci à moi c'est de voir que dans
les écoles publiques y en a pas
suffisamment et ça c'est certain que ça
va faire des enfants qui auront pas eu
cette chance
cette richesse d'expérience que les
autres pauvres et thierry une dernière
question de paloma a fait et comment
faire thierry pour que les enfants
puissent être bien sont formés pour
prendre la décision entre les temps
d'écran pour refaire des choses
intelligentes et créative est importante
et puis le temps qu il passe à faire des
choses qui peuvent être peut-être pas
très positif pour l'heure pour leur vie
alors ben écoutez je sais pas si la
question c'est pour vous personnellement
si vous savez j'ai eu une éducation des
enfants ce n'est pas simple et puis
avant les tablettes
il y avait la télévision via il ya des
parents qui ne limitait pas le temps de
voir la télévision d'eau qui goûtaient
ce temps devant la télé si certains
coordinateur cet encan et ses mobiles en
plus avec les téléphones intelligents
peut la voir dans sa poche
on ne pouvait pas faire avec la
télévision moi je
parce que les balises sont importantes
je pense que l'éducation est importante
je pense qu'il a mis les enfants être
responsable dans cet usage
ça doit faire partie de la
responsabilité de l'école mais des
parents aussi donc il n'ya pas de temps
idéal et certains gourous experts qui
vont vous dire il faut 20 minutes 30
minutes par jour
moi je pense que le type d'usagé d'abord
important qu'elles seront créés pendant
ce 30 minutes si on fait des devoirs
mais moi j'ai l'impression qu'on peut
être plus flexible donner plus de temps
si on joue à des jeux bella swan on peut
être plus restrictif en semaine parce
qu'elle l'école etc
et donc depuis libreville à qui la
caisse au la réponse c'est vous qui
l'avez paloma et monique guibout rapport
comprenant que si votre enfant vous dit
j'aimerais faire deux heures de jeu
vidéo soit peut-être que ces contenus
peut-être que j'ai minutes ou peut-être
qu'il peut y avoir des heures qu'une
idée pour la semaine mais il n'y a pas
de bonne réponse ans il faut trouver un
équilibre mais au delà de l'écran je
pense qu'il faut regarder quels types
d'usagés fait naître au coût de parents
qui se soucie de sa merci d'avoir
éclairé mon choix c'est très très
pertinente vous avons écouté là on est
tous plus outillé pour prendre certaines
décisions il c'est autour de la table on
va vérifier ça dans quelques jours ses
rites merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
notre invitation aujourd'hui alors que
cette fille de thierry karsenti qui est
titulaire de la chaire de recherche du
canada sur les technologies de
l'information et de la communication et
il nous parlait de l'université de
montréal
nous allons maintenant fermer notre
effort autre chose va réapparaître un
autre mystère
j'ai pour vous maintenant notre premier
jeu de la question connu et vous le
cerveau adam et vous le savez vous
le canada dépensent plus pour
l'éducation par personne que tout autre
pays du g8 mais sur 72 pays voici la
question où se situe le canada sur la
liste des pays qui ont le meilleur
système d'éducation au monde
selon donc le cd sur 72 on est combien
vous allez on est parmi les meilleurs
prestre raciale g77
ces jeux lançait alors je sais faire et
puis à marie 15e 20e les logiciels 10e
bah alors qui a répondu le plus proche
de la bonne réponse
nous sommes quatrièmes on est les pays
scandinaves ont même rentrer le félin
oui on est dépassé seulement par
singapour ce tout petit même le gentil
et puis l'estonie l'estonie mais
maintenant on parle de l'allemagne la
suède qui sont bien devant le canada
savoir c'est quoi les critères quand
même terminé à écouter on a mis ça sur
trois ans travers unis veulent une
valvule maison
l'évaluation qu'on dit scrupuleux mes
connaissances acquises par les élèves de
15 ans en sciences en lecture et en
mathématiques
d'accord vous plaît vraie matière et le
canada pardonnez moi c'est plus fort que
moi beaucoup de dames à l'école alors
canada est classée 5e reste un gars pour
le japon l'estonie et la finlande en
mathématiques et en lecture et pour ce
qui est de conscience on a un excellent
rendement à peu prés 6ème 7ème
bonjour si tout le monde fait la même
chose mais ici au canada je pense que
les gens
le trafic près par les enfants pour ça
oui peut-être que c'est partout comme ça
je ne l'aimé c'est pas commun au moins
un élève sur ma faim avant on va voir
combien ce que tous savent détecter un
hôtel mathias non préparés à une telle
date de ma faute
en fait cette semaine j'ai lu un article
dans le journal de montreal gazette qui
fait ca fait une opinion a qui disent
qui expliquait comment les québec
particulièrement le québec devrait
s'inspirer des listes d'éducation aux
fins en finlande
parce que en finlande justement on
n'évalue pas les enfants avec 2,6 à main
le professeur en les regardant
travailler prendre des notes
et puis qui évalue les enfants comme ça
donc il s'est vite ces jeunes-là d'avoir
lé stress de test et d être évaluée de
cette manière c'est reçu sans jambes pas
de devoir non plus puis les arts de
l'école sont beaucoup moins - non je
pense aux cinq heures par jour par
exemple ce qu'on reproche la réforme
scolaire
[Musique]
justement qui avait pas d'évaluation que
c'était trop arbitraire ou que c'était
trop libre je suis partisan des devoirs
cinq individus sommes pas 5 2 ans
minimum chaque soir au point de
pratiquement niveau primaire ou
secondaire primaire on apprenait à
widnes on sait ça use
mais je regarde où il termine ses cours
à 15h10 et elles restent à l'école après
pendant à peu près une heure et demie
puis elle fait des devoirs et elle en a
d'autres à terminer à la maison écoutez
parlons pas des devoirs ce soir une
prochaine émission
voilà lorsqu'on parade des gros débat
des papes tous ceux qui ont qui ont pas
terminé l'école qui ont ce qui comme des
décrocheurs viendra là dessus un jour
voici j'ai eu en question tam-tam qu'on
a mis sur facebook
cette semaine pour susciter de l'intérêt
et on a attrapé un beau poisson qu'on
adore une véritable baleine elle est
française
c'est une amie donc je peux dire ce
match aller vous parler de notre
auditrice comme une baleine même
depardieu vous êtes vraiment dur à vivre
j'imagine qu'on parlait de madame
depardieu c'est françoise depardieu et
on lui a posé la question suivante elle
d'autres pouvaient répondre ils n'ont
pas fait beaucoup d internautes qui s'y
trouve est notre question est un peu
large parce qu'en fait vous expliquez
que au canada le système de juridiction
provinciale
donc quand on passe du système scolaire
canadien mais en fait on ne peut pas
vraiment sûrement provincial puis au
sima les communautés autochtones c'est
différent aussi alors on va vraiment se
prononcent ils ont peut-être dans
l'ensemble du canada
voilà quelle était cette question la
question était beaucoup de canadiens se
vante d'avoir l'un des meilleur système
d'éducation gratuit au monde si vous
pouviez changer quelque chose à l'école
de votre enfance ou à celle de vos
enfants de vos petits enfants qu'est ce
que ce serait alors notre auditrice
préféré perdu en france répond la chose
suivante un modèle marie de france alors
madame depardieu nous dit bonjour les
amis du canada quelle question
fondamentale que vous vous posez et dont
tout parent qui suit le moindrement de
proches la progression de ses enfants à
l'école connaît la réponse
hooley réponse
car nos écoles sont construites sur des
traditions du passé pour ne pas dire
dépassé dans mon temps on interdisait
les calculatrices à l'école lors des
examens
personnellement j'ai coulé plusieurs
examens dans les cours de sciences non
pas parce que je ne savais pas raisonner
mais que calculée me prenais tout mon
temps je pense qu'il est fondamental
d'enseigner aux enfants comment com
comment raisonner et non comment
calculer le temps investi dans
l'apprentissage automatique et
répétitive donne des résultats nuls
vingt ans plus tard très souvent qui
aujourd'hui s'amuse à faire une division
complice avec un crayon et un bout de
papier nos écoles doivent s'ouvrir de
toute grande à l'utilisation des
nouvelles technologies et libérer
l'enfant pour qu'il consacre son temps à
la créativité et elle termine en disant
j'ai trop souffert à l'école étant
enfant et je constate que mes deux fils
pour les mêmes raisons sont passés eux
aussi par là on n'est pas plusieurs
d'entre nous sommes passés par
l'apprentissage automatique
les cent femmes a dit j'aime pas aller à
l'école
c'est dommage parce que moi j'adorerais
aller à l'école j'ai message mais
apprendre jeu mais apprendre de
nouvelles choses à voir de nouveaux
projets donc je trouve triste mais enfin
et d'autres nice mais aussi dit ça je
veux pas mettre une heure de course et
tout pas que l'on voit si on a une part
la nouvelle technologie ant émission
nous on va de l'avant
alors on a une vidéo qui vous présente
nos coups de coeur cette semaine à radio
canada international puisque plusieurs
de nos e journaliste et annonceurs se
sont intéressés à la question du retour
en classe
et voici quelque chose peut pas réparer
mon des marteaux et vous me dites qu'on
s'est lancé voilà raymond des bateaux et
qui parlait qu'à parler alain lalonde un
professeur en francisation passionnés de
son boulot et il en singles français ou
nouveaux arrivants on écoute
[Musique]
à l'est la londe et professeur en
francisation fait deux communautés
vivent ici de nouveaux arrivants et mon
invité dans les studios ces réseaux
canada international est la langue
bonjour bonjour comment ce qu'on devient
prof de français
mais pour nouveau eu lieu ben on devient
prof premièrement phase en phase 1 et
ben non ça dépend de l'intérêt peut-être
de chacun moi je suis arrivé à ça parce
que j'étais depuis longtemps intéressé
par ce qui se passe à yazoo voyager
beaucoup en amérique latine j'ai essayé
de m'ouvrir au monde et puis lorsque je
suis revenu c'est pendant longtemps j'ai
voulu retourner dans ces pays doit
permettre en donner la vie maumené
ailleurs j'ai une famille et c'est alors
je me suis dit si je peux pas aller
retourner au monde je vais faire venir
le monde ce que j'enseigne j'ai déjà
voilà et on a coupé sa cour mais vous
pouvez aller beaucoup plus loin dans la
découverte de cette entrevue c'est sûr à
20 h 30
c'est bien cette bonne réaction en fait
on a failli partir sur la lune
alors c'est sûr la passe de tam-tam
canada à la suite de cette entrevue de
neuf minutes entre raymond des marteaux
est un spécialiste de la francisation
j'ai peut-être ici une question par
rapport à la francisation et le nombre
d'élèves allophones
il augmente beaucoup sur le territoire
ici à montréal sur l'île de montréal
parfait sur au centre-ville de montréal
au point où des écoles primaires
aujourd'hui beaucoup beaucoup majorité
d'enfants qui ne sont ni de langue
maternelle française ou anglaise
quand on dit une majorité d'enfants qui
ne sont ni de langue maternelle
française sur dix élèves combien sont
des à nos fans ok donc sur l'île la
grande île de montréal ce nom sur le
centre-ville de montréal à sa façon à
6,6 il ya six ou sept secondes réponse
est non c'était 7 la dernière fois mais
la c9
ce niveau je crois pas j'ai beaucoup
discuté le croire
[Musique]
gg c'est uniquement parce qu'il dit au
journal la presse de moyens je vais pas
dire si la coalition mais non mais ils
sont des sources fiables fiable il y
avait toute la liste les statistiques
ok mais de d'un quartier en particulier
au centre-ville
oui centre-ville ici dans le quartier
près de là du quartier des spectacles de
montréal où il ya énormément de familles
immigrants dont des écoles où 90% des
gestes mais ça paraît beaucoup anglaise
mais je ne parle pas l'anglais vous
aider vous aimez tellement l'école
cruellement vous y retournez à
pratiquement à chaque fois qu'il ya une
occasion ce que c'était il ya combien de
temps il ya quelques mois vous avez
parlé de noël fait une vidéo au sujet
d'une web documentaire d'un
webdocumentaire qui la petite juste
maquis qui documente la façon dont les
jeunes qui viennent d'arriver au québec
ça s'apprivoise la langue l'école donc à
prévoir la langue à l'école étrangers 1
parce que je peux vous dire moi j'ai
passé par là pas de deux les partis en
afrique à l'âge de 2 ans survenue au
québec à 11 ans entre les deux j'ai
passé une année dans le service service
à la suppression de l'école des écoles
comme un coq et aliments
c'est différent car pays ou trois pistes
sur un trois pays sur et c'était fou oui
c'est juste un choix
oui et puis aux habitudes différentes il
ya les écoles en afrique sénégal
africaine public
je passais par là souvent il y avait la
technique c'était de mettre les premiers
classe odeo au devant des classes donc
j'ai quand on n'a rien lâché en moi on
la liste bouger un peu bon mamie à
l'arrière la 1er journée parce que
j'étais arrive la première évaluation de
mots plus tard on met en troisième
position
et là mon père a dit des sports aura pas
c'était pas très fort
tu avais pas très bon c'est comme ça
mais je pense qu'il l'autre enseignement
alors ben oui parce que je dois plutôt à
quand alors moi j'étais parmi les
meilleurs mais j'étais un cancre alors
je des fois j'ai moi même je regardais
cette technique de mettre les meilleurs
en avant en disant mais les maires de
soissons il arrive à suivre facilement
c'est ça il faut qu'il soit un arrière
fabrics mais oui exactement et alors il
ya plusieurs techniques et pas une bonne
équipe une meilleure école par rapport à
une eau je pense qu'il ya plusieurs
différentes formes d'école - il devrait
y en avoir plusieurs sortes d'écoles
pour les différentes personnalités 1
enfants n'étudient pas de la même façon
que son voisin
les intel et intelligence et toute son
intelligence sa wii est-ce qu'on peut
regarder la vidéo sur le web de
caractère de la loma un extrait en tout
cas qu'on écoute
[Musique]
moi j'ai été approché par la com ça
scolaire de montréal et l'uqam eux fait
souhaiter d'augmenter leurs démarches de
recherche parce qu'ils ont été parfois
notre projet d'environ quatre ans avec
des écoles directement à travailler avec
les directions d'école les enseignants
pour améliorer les pratiques surtout
concernant le passage en fait des
classes d'accueil aux places qu'on
appelle qu'ordinaire le secteur parce qu
il remarqué un problème le à ce niveau
là et qu'ils avaient un impact sur la
réussite scolaire donc se sont penchés
sur cette question le est en fait tu
voulais un peu partagé cette recherche
le soutien à travers les autres
enseignants les autres actions d'école
pour qu'ils puissent avoir des nouvelles
des à propos des l'accueil des élèves
jusqu'à qu'est ce qu'est ce qui était le
plus grand défi pour vous parce qu'être
les jeunes qui arrivent de partout dans
le monde a ri puis l'apprentissage de la
langue française c'est peut être le
principal objectif des sept de ces
classes d'accueil là mais ce que la
langue avec une des filles il ya eu
d'autres défis pour la création de ce
web documentaire mais en fait ça se
savait pas si on parle du contenu du
continent là mais au niveau du contenu m
qui était très fort ce qu'on apprend à
travers le web documentaire en fait
c'est que ça prend cinq à sept pour
maîtriser une nouvelle langue et c'est
un concept des fois qu'on oublie parce
que bon parce que les enfants vont
apprendre rapidement et on pense aussi
qu'ils sont beaux capable d'apprendre
d'autres matières
s'ils ne maîtrisent pas le français ce
qui est paul que en fait c'est souvent
en mathématiques par exemple ils vont
être capables de comprendre des notions
même s'ils maîtrisent pas tout à fait la
langue française et ses deux qu'ils
puissent continuer dans l'apprentissage
il n'en peut qu'il soit bloqué juste
parce qu'ils sont pas encore
les choses iraient beaucoup d'autres
choses à apprendre c'était qu'un extrait
et puis soudain loire tout la sq a
préparé paloma il ya quelques temps sur
la passage de l'école et de la du
français à l'école
parmi ceux qui arrivent chez nous bien
c'est sur la page de tam-tam canada
cette semaine dernière peu dernier petit
referme cette parenthèse belle émission
presque sûr ça me des bons élèves mais
je ne peux pas quoi je porte ce jugement
parce que monsieur tepa voici quand même
une question qui sera à l'examen
d'accords quel est le pourcentage des
élèves québécois qui sont ni à
l'extérieur du canada ou que l'un de
leurs parents est né à l'extérieur du
pays québécois l'ensemble du québec la
page us montreal non pas juste le
centre-ville dans pourcentage des élèves
québécois qui sont nés à l'extérieur du
canada
donc que l'un de leurs parents est né à
l'extérieur je tairai un sur trois sade
et 33 pour ça moi c'est pas la ba 103 %
c'est bien ce pays fou de québec
oui du québec du québec tamoul et yahia
42 % qu'est ce qui vous fait dire ça car
je regarde déjà juste autour de la table
senso on est déjà à 4 sur 5
mais on n'est pas au lac saint jean non
mais ils m'ont quand même 65 ou 67 53 %
si vous avez 10 67% vous auriez
également eu la mauvaise séquence
c'est quoi la bonne réponse 23 ans
bravo parce que je sais qu'à montréal
c'était autour de 50% de la population
c'est pratiquement la moitié de la
population québécoise s'est dit vieux
sondages ça fait déjà quelques années
les gros suspens selon les choses
évoluent rapidement ils le disent mme y
avait vingt mille étudiants qui en 2012
qui apprenaient à la maison l'école à la
maison au niveau canadien mais on pense
que ça augmente de 12 15 % par année
noire fait des bonds extraordinaire bon
ce signe des temps aujourd'hui de
l'avant il bougeait puis veulent amener
aux enfants avec eux je voulais offrir
notre coup de coeur c'est ainsi un peu
petit une petite cerise sur le gâteau je
trouve à preuve on fumait son horizon et
voici ce que ça donne c'est nos
meilleurs reportages cette semaine et
nos coups de coeur
d'ailleurs pourquoi un médecin québécois
va-t-il de 25% moins de patients que
celui de notre province
c'est une statistique sortie 7 ce qui
prend plus de temps avec chacun non
sinon passé
non c'est pas une question pareille
c'est une question des coupes fait jouer
on va avoir la réponse bientôt pourquoi
est ce qu'ils sont ils par an contre
moins de deux patients ça c'est une
enquête de l'association médicale
canadienne et on as un sondage national
et on va voir un extrait d'une entrevue
réalisée avec un spécialiste qui vous
explique un instant quel est le problème
est exactement ce n'est pas de la
paresse loin de là c'est un problème de
bureaucratie de paperasse
c'est moins le problème pour le reste du
canada parce qu'ils ont investi d'une
façon importante dans le développement
de première ligne au québec on est une
décentralisée à l'hôpital alors 50 % de
toutes nos omnipraticiens qui
fondamentalement c'est eux qui fait axel
les scènes famille travail dans
l'hôpital de levin professeur associé à
la faculté de médecine de l'université
mcgill à montréal et ancien directeur de
l' agence de santé des services sociaux
de montréal
à l'hôpital ils ont accès à l'équipement
de la technologie de l'imagerie ils ont
accès à des spécialistes pour avoir un
consultation parce que des fois l'onu a
besoin de sens et c'est bien de
travailler à l'hôpital
très inquiet mais vous n'avez pas accès
à la technologie
vous n'avez pas une équipe vous n'avez
pas des assistantes pour vous aider à
broder clients alors le nombre de
personnes que médecins inscrits d'ici
est moindre et prestement
c'est la raison pour laquelle on n'a pas
excellent mais alors ce point et un
rapide en outre choses cette semaine
fait partie des coups de coeur
le véhicule électrique si tout le monde
en avait un mais au québec on pourrait
la [ __ ] déficit commercial le monde
achète de pétrole à l'étranger où le
million des millions de dollars en tout
cas l'explication de stéphane pascal ont
récité rôle innovant qui nous coûtent en
moyenne 20% moins cher que son
équivalent qui permet de réaliser pour
le consommateur des économies d'environ
200 dollars par mois la réduction de la
facture des privés laisser su que vous
représentez souligne qu' on pourrait
réduire sérieusement le déficit
commercial du québec un poussin usage du
véhicule électrique
différents organismes qui démontre que
actuellement la province du québec
importe ils étaient 30
étonnamment la courbe du déficit
commercial du québec suit et fluctue
selon le monde dans l'importation du
pétrole
donc si on regarde en 2013 on importe
près de 15 milliards de pétrole et on
avait un déficit commercial qui était de
l'ordre de 17 18 milliards en 2015 on a
importé 9 milliards de pétrole avec un
déficit commercial t2 8 milliards en
2016 on a importé 7 milliards de pétrole
avec un déficit commercial de 6
milliards actuellement notre déficit
diminue parce que le prix du pétrole
diminue mais décrit prix du pétrole
devrait augmenter notre déficit va
augmenter la suite donc sur la page de
tam-tam canada cette semaine
est ce que vous entendez j'espère
souvenir des plans tordus non plus
maintenant
non non il ya quelque chose d'autre que
vous devriez en attendant ce moment vous
l'entendez pas le style non non non rien
à voir avec ma voix s'entendait pas non
plus non non ben voyons ben oui c'est la
sonnerie la fin de la classe parce qu'on
a déjà
computer fraud journée
[Musique]